Speaker 1: Progressive union organizer Brandon
Johnson. Let's go. Brandon. Has been elected
mayor of Chicago, Illinois. Well, certainly now
the police will be defunded, right? No. In fact,
Brandon Johnson has outlined a very sensible plan
for reforming and continuing to improve policing
in Chicago. HuffPost Reports. Brandon
Johnson, progressive union organizer,
elected mayor of Chicago. Johnson's victory over
centrist Paul Vallas is a major achievement for
the activist left. That is absolutely the case.
Johnson is described in this article as a black
leftist and former school. Paul Vallas was
the former CEO of Chicago Public Schools.
This victory is being called again by HuffPost,
one of the starkest ideological proxy battles
in the annals of recent municipal politics. And
it is a historic achievement for the activist left
likely to have ripple effects across the country.
Okay, that's the characterization by HuffPost.
There's a lot there. It may be the case. It may
not be. This is super interesting for a number
of different reasons. First of all, remember that
the former mayor of Chicago, Lori Lightfoot, lost
her primary. That's interesting in and of itself.
Sometimes when you see folks positioned like Lori
Lightfoot lose primaries, it's because there's a
resurgence by the right, meaning that you're going
to see some hardcore conservative or whatever the
case may be. Chicago is not a conservative city,
so it's not particularly likely. But sometimes
when you see incumbents defeated, it's because
of a big shift. This is a shift, but it is a
shift to the left. And it's another reminder
that a lot of these Republicans in different parts
of the country, I know Chicago is its own thing.
But it's a warning. If you combine this with the
results from Wisconsin to right wingers that they
need to run and meet voters where they actually
are, not whether they are not where they might
wrongly imagine voters to be. And it is a reality
in the United States that on issues, on just about
every issue, most parts of the country have moved
to the left. Now, that obviously depends on where
you started. More conservative areas have moved
to the left, but they're still conservative, just
less so. And more progressive areas have moved to
the left and they're becoming more progressive.
The abortion results in Kansas are a reminder of
that. So it's going to be interesting to follow
this. It's also an incredible path for Brandon
Johnson to this eventual victory. When he started
before the first round of voting in Chicago. He
was polling 2% and now he got himself to winning
the runoff and now becoming the mayor of Chicago.
So he will be judged by the results. This is a
victory ideologically for the progressive left.
Now, he actually has to come in and make things
happen. Of course, Republicans around the country
often love to point to Chicago as the example of
just devastating anti-police politicking. And
what happens when you hamper police and crime
explodes and gun violence and all these different
things. Of course, we know how to zoom out and to
take a more fact based view when it comes to gun
violence in Chicago, despite Chicago's strict gun
laws. You drive 40 minutes to Indiana or I think
it's like 60 or 70 minutes to Wisconsin, and all
of a sudden it's much easier to get firearms. And
you have to account for that when it comes to, oh,
they want to defund the police. Defund the police.
Almost no one wants to defund the police. Sure,
you can find some activists on the left that say
defund. Almost everyone says reform. And indeed,
Brandon Johnson plans to reform the police. And
in some cases, from what I've seen him say, it
might require actually adding funding in order to
achieve things through new programs that they want
to start. So we're going to watch and see. But a
big night for the left, a win in Wisconsin, a win
in Chicago. And yes, we also saw the failed former
president Donald Trump arrested. We will talk
about that after the break. Now that we've gotten
to some of this very, very good news. The David
Pakman Show is an audience supported program. We
primarily depend on you to fund our program if
you appreciate what we do or even if you don't
like it, but think it's worthwhile to have it.
You can sign up at join Packman dot com. You can
use the coupon code indicted or you can use the
coupon code indicated the way Donald Trump wrongly
spelled indicted in that troth essential post the
other day you'll get instant access to the bonus
show commercial free audio and video feeds of the
show and you'll get the entire program every day,
hours before it is released publicly on all of our
different platforms. Sign up at join Pacman dot
com coupon code indicted or indicated your choice.